- Well, I heard that you liked Reese's,
so I thought I would bring you some.
I think Justin might have
some, some Reese's coming out.
- No.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I think so.
- [Male Guest] No.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I think, yep.
(audience applauding)
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yep.
(Kelly Clarkson imitating horn sounds)
(male guest clapping)
- Oh my God
- That's, that's. Thank you, Justin.
- Oh my God.
- Yeah.
Here's my.
Okay.
Oh, that's nice. That's nice.
Wait, here's my thing.
Let's be real, though.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna hand it
to y'all, Reese's right now.
Cause see this ratio, this is off.
This is not.
(audience laughing)
You think it's gonna
be the same, it's not.
You gotta go for, this
is not the right ratio.
I just wanted to pull this out
to help you out as a company.
- [Male Guest] Yeah.
(audience laughing)
Um, it's not the, it's not
the right ratio. It's not.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Take it from me.
Um, it's not, it's not as good.
I'm like, there's too much chocolate.
There's not enough peanut, whatever.